all the talk today is about are we going
to see inflation or deflation and before
we do that i think it's really important
to get up a micro economic level
understanding of why do prices increase
or decrease and so we'll do a little
example of
me starting a business and and when the
do the prices increase or decrease in
that market so let's say i wanted to
start a
a cupcake factory
cupcakes
cupcake
factory and then actually in the process
of this video even though this isn't the
intent of this playlist the intent of
this playlist is eventually for you to
be able to go to your econ professor and
say no we you know we won't or we will
have inflation or deflation for reasons
x y and z but in the process you might
learn a little bit about accounting and
and starting a cupcake factory so let's
say i want to start a cupcake factory it
costs a million dollars to build
so one million dollars
to build
and just the economics of the factories
it costs five hundred thousand dollars
five hundred thousand dollars a year to
operate
so that's literally to pay the electric
bills to have people sitting there uh
ready to make cupcakes and i have
accountants and
you know all the rest i have to pay
people to clean the place
and let's say the economics of the
cupcakes themselves
the cost per cupcake
so is one dollar
cost let me do that in red because
actually i'll do all of these in red
because these are
i'll do that later
so the cost per cupcake is a dollar
one dollar cost
per cupcake
and where does that cost well that's you
know some of it is the incremental let's
assume that i had a completely
automated robotic factory so there's
actually you know let's say there's very
little labor at my factory and this is
just the cost of ingredients you know
cream and sugar and butter and you know
those little wax paper things that the
cupcakes held in and the electricity to
run my robots and then you know over
time to kind of maintain the robots that
make my that make my factory and
so what what would be the echo let's say
i think that the general you know that i
can charge two dollars per cupcake
two dollars per cupcake
so just as an exercise let's think about
oh and one other thing my one million
dollar factory can produce
can produce one million cupcakes
one million cupcakes
per year so this is a couple of
exercises because i'm a businessman i'm
not just going to plunk down a million
dollars before i
before i figure out how much money i can
make let's think about how much money we
can make in different scenarios so let's
say let's call this scenario one which
is kind of the best scenario
so call this the optimistic
optimist is that i sell
a million cupcakes so my factory can
produce a million cupcakes and i sell a
million
cupcakes if i sell one million cupcakes
and i'll take a side here because this
is a an issue that i want to bring up a
lot i am fully utilized my factory can
produce 1 million cupcakes and i in this
scenario
i'm producing a million cupcakes so we
would say we're 100 utilized how much
are you producing relative to what you
can produce 100
so if i sell a million cupcakes what
would be my revenue
and i won't go into the details of
accounting let me make revenue in green
because that's a good thing
so what is my revenue if my background
weren't already black i would make that
in black and that's why people say being
in the black or being in the red because
being in the black means you're positive
and being in the red means you're
negative but my background is blacks
while i use green so we'll say being in
the green
so what would be my revenue well i'm
selling one million cupcakes
and this is my optimistic scenario let's
say i i actually am able to charge two
dollars per cupcake and we'll have a
obviously the whole discussion is what
happens to this price over a bunch of
different scenarios
so i am able to charge two dollars per
cupcake so my revenue is equal to
two million dollars per year
right i produce a million this is a
million cupcakes per year
what are my cost of goods
cost of goods and i'll write the common
acronym there cogs and you know this is
what you'll see if you actually look at
income statements for uh for companies
public companies you will see something
like cost of goods or um
or you know variable cost but usually
actually cost of goods or cost of
services is what you'll see most often
and so if i have a million cupcakes oh
let me do this in red i said i would do
in red so i have a million cupcakes
times what's my cost per cupcake times
one dollar cost per cupcake
so it's a one dollar
one million dollars per year
and so what is my profit just from
selling the cupcakes before i think
about how much does it cost for me to
you know all of the overhead expenses
just kind of the money i'm just getting
from selling the cupcakes and that term
is called gross profit
gross
profit
and that's essentially how much am i
bringing in from the cupcakes and then
how much are just those cupcakes costing
me
so i'll do a line here i'll subtract
that from that
so gross profit i am making
1 million dollars 2 minus 1.
you might say oh that's great i'm making
a million you're making a million
dollars on your cupcake factory in the
scenario i was like oh no we're not done
yet this is just the gross profit this
is just the money directly from the
cupcakes but i had all i have all of
this overhead expense and oftentimes on
a regular income statement it'll be
called selling general and
administrative or overhead costs or
operating costs or or something like
that i'll just call it overhead i'll
make it red because it's an expense so
this should be
read to
cogs
and so i'll call it overhead
once again that's kind of the offices
and the accountants and the bookkeepers
so that's going to be 500 000 a year
and then how much am i making from the
business now
from the business and this is called
operating profit
operating profit how much am i making
from operating the business
and i won't go into all of the details
of an income statement but any income
statement you look at will have this
operating profit line and everything
below the operating profit line just as
an aside will kind of cover things not
related to the actual operations of the
business it'll you know it'll be
expenses related to financing the
business if i took a loan for that
million dollars or it'll be expenses
related to taxes and all of that but
we're just assuming a world an ideal
world that doesn't have taxes and let's
say i assume you know i inherited this
million dollars so i didn't finance it
so my operating profit is really my
profit because i'm not i don't have to
pay taxes on it so let's see i got gross
profit just from selling the cupcakes a
million
overhead
the accountants and the people cleaning
the factory and et cetera et cetera
that's 500 000 a year so my operating
profit is five hundred thousand dollars
and that's pretty good i mean i had a
one million dollar investment
one-time investment and i'm assuming
that this five hundred thousand uh to a
year to operate it also maintains my
building so this kind of one million
dollar investment will
exist forever
right and i'm making five hundred
thousand dollars a year in this scenario
so that's a fifty percent return right
which is great if i told you i had an
investment where i could make fifty
percent a year on your money you'd say
oh yeah here's here's my money here's a
check
but that's this is of course an
optimistic scenario let's let's let's
think of other centers and there's
actually a ton of scenarios because you
can keep adjusting how much you sell and
the price you sell it for and come up
with different numbers here and it's
actually a fun exercise to do in excel
and you can do probability distributions
and all that but i won't worry about
that right now let's do a pessimistic
well actually let's let's let's do the
scenario what do i have to do just to
make sure that i don't lose money right
so to make sure i i don't lose money
let's let's do it let's kind of do it
backwards
so we're going to do a break even
analysis
and trust me this will eventually lead
to whether we are seeing we are going to
see inflation or deflation in this
economy and i think in the in the in the
meantime you might learn a little
interesting things about about starting
a business
but so let's say i want to i just want
to know
i just want to know what what has to
happen for my operating profit to be
zero right to not be negative what's the
minimum number of cupcakes i need to
make or what price i have to charge so
if my operating profit is zero
we know
my overhead
the overhead
this is fixed this is a fixed expense
there's nothing i can do about it just
if you want to have a cupcake factory it
will cost you five hundred thousand
and all right as a negative number
because we're going to subtract it from
the gross profit
so what does the gross profit have to be
so the gross profit
the gross profit in order for this to
come out to be zero the gross profit has
to be five hundred
thousand dollars
and so now we can say we can think of a
bunch of scenarios where we end up with
500 000 gross profit
we could
if we sold
what did we say if we sold a so how can
we get to 500 000 let's say we're
selling
i don't know instead of selling a
million cupcakes we're only selling 500
000 cupcakes
500 000 cupcakes right this should work
out so then our revenue
will be
500k and let's say i'm still selling it
for two dollars a cupcake
times
two dollars
and so that would be one million dollars
of revenue coming into the door per year
and then my cost of cupcakes
or my cost of goods sold is what i
should be doing this in red i'm not
being consistent
my cost of goods sold
is what
we said is a dollar per cupcake right so
it's 500 000 times one dollar and really
just you know i mean it would be silly
to ever sell a cupcake for less than a
dollar right then i mean you're just
you're just kind of handing checks out
to your cupcake eaters but anyway in
this case
my cost of good gold sold would be minus
five hundred thousand and everything
would work out so this is a break even
scenario where i sell 500 000 cupcakes
at two dollars per cupcake with this
being the cost of goods and then i'll
make 500 000 gross profit and then take
out the overhead and at least i won't
make a loss but this is interesting
because this tells me if i'm charging
two dollars per cupcake i have to sell
at least i have to sell at least five
hundred thousand cupcakes
to make money so you might say oh yeah
so it would be it would never be
rational it would never be rational to
sell anything less than 500 000 cupcakes
otherwise you shouldn't operate the
business and what we'll do in future
videos is we'll actually explore
situations in which that does happen and
in which people will start to kind of
cut prices to actually compete
and in the process they'll be doing very
irrational things but anyway i realize
i'm running up to i've run out of time
in this video i'll see you in the next
one and we'll actually see what happens
once i start my cupcake factory